ce fut un grand vaisseau taillé dans
l'acier massif sa coque est d'un bleu
azur et son avenir est inconnue tout ce
qu'on peut nous dire pour l'instant
c'est qu'elle est phagocyté est
inutilisable puisque il a cet hiver
frappé le grand écueil d'un service
fiable les voyageurs ont dû faire le
deuil
les bateaux eurent subi quelques pays de
saint-denis hommage à ce en hommage à
ces propulseurs ont révélé leur
fragilité et il est depuis en cale sèche
remisé l'image était forte
le traversier mise en service il ya
trois ans et demi à peine était de
sceller par un remorqueur
aujourd'hui le vaisseau d'or et la
société des traversiers cherche toujours
qui a tort oh mon but cette fois la
lumière sort peut comprendre ce qui
s'est passé ce fut un vaisseau d'or
taillé avec 170 millions de l'argent des
contribuables qui pourraient craindre
citron nous avons retrouvé d'anciens
employés de la société des traversiers
du québec qui ont été aux premières
loges de la construction du f à gauthier
et malgré leur crainte de représailles
ils ont accepté de nous révéler des
faits troublants sur ce qu'ils ont vu
sur le chantier c'était tellement
inacceptable tellement de majeur qu'une
société avec des responsables se
conduisent cette façon c'est pour ça que
je témoigne aujourd'hui les jambes
droites sawa jetant des taux qui a été
payé par l'argent
des contribuables bienvenue à godbout un
village sur la côte nord
quelques maisons bord du fleuve mais
godbout est un peu triste dans ce mois
de juin
le traversier ne vient plus et la gare
maritime est déserte
même chose à baie comeau ces deux ports
accueille le traversier qui relie la
côte nord à matane sur la rive sud du
saint laurent
le f à gauthier est en panne et le petit
traversy qui le remplace ne peut
naviguer que par temps calme
le traversier fait partie de la vie à
gauche et justin et stratégiques le
fleuve les gars le québec qui fait
géographiquement comme soit qu'un grand
fleuve il faut le traverser
rosaire gens habitent à godbout depuis
plusieurs années il voit le kit chez lui
il a voyagé plusieurs fois à bord du f
abouti depuis que le traversier est
arrivé flambant neuf en 2015
c'est un magnifique bateau je peux vous
dire que vraiment il ya beaucoup de
styles il y a de la gueule c'est plutôt
un bateau un design vraiment intéressant
mais rose et argent a vite déchanté
quand j'étais au contraire ce qu'on paie
le partage des le bateau prend le large
je trouvais que bateau l'homme
présentait des vibrations un petit peu
anormal même à la retraite
un ingénieur qui a travaillé toute sa
vie avec de la machinerie industrielle
lourde ne perd pas ses réflexes monsieur
jean questionne alors un membre de
l'équipage
jeudi et cotait trouve pas que ce bateau
levé anormalement de personnes m'a dit
je suis c'est comme ça ah ok
rosaire gens regardent les nouvelles et
comme tout le monde voit le f à gauthier
a cumulé les avaries et bien à peine six
mois après sa première traversée le fr
gauthier qui relie matin dans le corner
fera un séjour de quelques temps à
qu'elle sèche quelques 120 prix ont été
constatées sur le fr grutiers notamment
dans le système de ventilation dans le
système électrique
le réservoir à eau chaude une anomalie
qui a été détectée sur des génératrices
et le système de propulsion au gaz
naturel liquéfié qui ne fonctionne pas
l'équipage a décrit le navire à 1 milles
au large de la côte en raison d'une
avarie du moteur et d'un manque de
courant généralisée un problème du
système électronique a été détecté lors
de l'entretien mais la société des
traversiers du québec maintient que les
navires et bien construit et non ce
n'est pas un rafiot non ce n'est pas un
instant rosaire j'en écris donc courriel
à la société des traversiers
pas de réponse puis en novembre dernier
il rencontre par hasard une membre du
conseil d'administration de la société
n'a jeté en bus la bonne personne je
dois admettre que j'étais très directe
poli je ne sais pas mais c'était ferme
et je lui enjoint jeudi ça peut pas
durer je dis engagez-vous un film de
consulter en vibration je vous assure
que vous faites pas un kilomètre au
large que la personne dont vous dire de
retourner aux côtés d'antonio par c10 ne
viendrait pas sécuritaire il n'a aucune
nouvelle suivant ces discussions l'offre
le point mort et j'ai du bambin jesu
mort d'avoir effet mais quelques
semaines plus tard
les événements lui donne enfin raison la
découverte d'un nouveau problème sur le
navire force la société des traversiers
a annulé les voyages à quelques jours de
noël pierre on a découvert un autre
problème les propulseurs azimuts on
vibre nous sommes en plein temps des
fêtes les gens sont privés du service
sur lequel ils doivent pouvoir compter
des gens comme isabelle caron qui se
serait bien passé de cela je dépendais
totalement de tout ça parce que sinon il
fallait que je fasse le tour par québec
c'est 860 km comme elle plusieurs
gaspésien travail sur la côte nord la
semaine et vice versa elle fait le
détour de 9h et enceinte jusqu'aux
oreilles à part de ça est-ce que je
porte rentrer travailler lendemain mes
clients est ce qu'ils vont être vu c'est
comment ça se passe si je peux pas les
voir ce que quelqu un groupe qui va
pouvoir revoir mon employeur c'est
qu'est-ce qui va passer de celui là
pendant ce temps les nouvelles du ffa
gauthier ne sont pas bonnes le navire
est fagots tier entre en cale sèche
aujourd'hui au chantier maritime davie à
lévis que les nouvelles puis je me dis
un jour ça l'avait pays ce qui m'a
surpris c'est qu'on l'attende soit
brisée pour l'arrêter
la société des traversiers louent
temporairement un autre navire pour les
camions et met en place un pont aérien
pour transporter les passagers comme ce
groupe de musiciens qui attend son vol
en gaspésie en direct de l'aéroport de
mont-joli faire quoi peu de brume
le groupe embarque chante aux passagers
la bien nommée saga sur les déboires du
f à wauthier
mais bon
[Musique]
et il y aura matière à écrire plusieurs
couplets en catastrophe
la société des traversiers achète un
bateau qui passera à l'histoire
le tristement célèbre apollon et les
vieux et les rouillé il sent les années
70 mais au moins ils fonctionnent mais
dix jours plus tard le traversier apollo
qui relie matane et la côte-nord a
heurté ce matin le quai de godbout on
voit cette grande cicatrice sur les
images
et comme si ce n'était pas assez après
être entré en collision avec le qe 2
gouttes bull mois dernier l'histoire se
répète
ok de matane
[Musique]
oh
non
[Musique]
finalement on se résigne à acheter un
autre navire le sarm a au final f à
gauthier a engendré des coûts bien plus
important que prévu
le prix pour le bateau seulement était
de 148 millions +22 millions pour les
plans les pièces et la mise en opération
plus 40 millions pour réaménager les
quais quatre fois le budget prévu est
tous les imprévus qui découle des bris
majeur du f à gauthier s'élève
maintenant à 60 millions de dollars
et le compteur tourne encore comment se
fait-il sa sortie d'un chantier naval
avait touché problème là qui a accepté
bateau là qui a approuvé les gens qui
étaient là et être capable de prouver
statut des gens il y avait des
compétences
nous quittons godbout et la côte nord
pour aller à la rencontre de témoins
directs de la construction du phare
gauthier en espérant qu'elle puisse nous
aider à faire la lumière sur toute cette
histoire
maintenant que vous savez à quel point
ça va mal pour les fagots pied après la
pause les révélations de nos témoins
clés
[Musique]
voici le f à wauthier comme vous le
verrez rarement
c'est du moins ce qu'espère le nouveau
pdg de la société des traversiers
stéphane la faune nous sommes au
chantier davie à lévis où les favoris
étant qu'elle sèche
le traversier presque neuf est à l'arrêt
depuis maintenant neuf mois en raison
d'un bris des propulseurs sadek
ossements même c'est la faulx est ce que
c'est cette pièce d'équipement là vous
voyez la reprends mon cauchemar c'était
surtout de recevoir les pièces codifie
d'abord on la société des traversiers en
profite pour devancer certains travaux
d'entretien pour ne pas avoir à
retourner le bateau en réparation l'an
prochain on va vous retournez navire en
bonne forme avant le début de l'hiver on
navire qui est sécuritaire et fiable et
c'est ce qu'on s'emploie à faire c'est
dans la timonerie que le nouveau pdg en
poste depuis six mois
accepte de répondre à nos questions mais
puisqu'ils n'étaient pas là pendant la
construction
il est accompagné de ceux qui ont
supervisé le projet on est conjuguée à
des défis mais je te loisirs que les
problématiques qu'on raconte ne sont pas
nécessairement nuisible à nos opérations
à part bien entendu l'événement de
l'hiver dernier puis affecté nos propres
hommes à part du fait que le bateau
n'avance plus depuis neuf mois alors
qu'il n'a que 4 ans ce serait un bien
beau navire
mais aujourd'hui le pdg a choisi de
faire une admission inattendue je vous
dirais pas qu on est épaté par la
qualité des valves des pompes
il ya un problème aussi que s'est
développée au niveau de la porte avant
du navire
donc quand je regarde le niveau de
durabilité qu'on pourrait espérer de
certaines de ces pièces là ce n'est pas
au rendez vous notre enquête révèle
plusieurs faits troublants qui n'ont pas
de lien avec le bris des propulseurs
mais qui pourrait expliquer ce manque de
qualité du navire
[Musique]
c'est ici en italie près de naples dans
ce chantier naval que le f à gauthier a
été construit entre 2013 et 2015
c'est fincantieri qui a fait la plus
basse soumission fincantieri c'est une
multinationale d'envergure qui construit
des navires de guerre comme des
paquebots
l'assemblage de la première section de
la coque a été complété en décembre 2013
on voit ici des grues qui la dépose sur
le lit de lancement où tout le navire
sera construit pendant cette
construction
la société des traversiers a dépêché en
alternance un petit groupe de ses
employés jma d'un engin de faire vos
chantiers c'est d'offrir notre présence
pour répondre aux questions et de suivre
le processus de qualité pas de le
surveiller pas de l'approuver c'était
pas notre essentiellement la société des
traversiers a fait confiance au système
de contrôle de qualité interne chez
fincantieri
le fabricant et à la surveillance d'une
société de classification
c'est une compagnie indépendante qui
doit certifier que le bateau répond à
certaines normes et selon benoît cormier
le système de contrôle les qualités a
bien fonctionné son navire leur
clairement est approuvée par une société
de location la pluie en dormant meilleur
par le ministère des transports est tenu
tous ses sorties corps étrange qu'un
système aussi rigoureux selon la société
des traversiers donne un navire qui a
cumulé briller les problèmes
nous avons cherché des réponses nous
avons retrouvé les employés de la
société qui était sur place pendant la
construction du un fagot thiais en
italie nous allons au bic au
bas-saint-laurent rencontré deux d'entre
eux qui ont accepté de nous raconter ce
qu'ils ont
moi ce que je souhaitais est de mettre
toute l'énergie que j'avais pour avoir
vraiment un très très bon avira dans la
région de matane rni lebrun et l
inspecteur chargé de la structure
d'acier de l'isolation et de la finition
si lui qui a séjourné le plus longtemps
en italie
il compte 40 ans d'expérience dans le
domaine naval donc 14 à l'emploi de la
société des traversiers
à mon arrivée on a une réunion où tous
les manuels de contrôle qualité nous et
nous ont été montrés expliqué après lors
du déroulement d'un fonctionnaire viru
s'apercevait très très bien que la
qualité au niveau du chantier n'était
pas là rené lebreux a vu un monde de
différence entre la théorie et la
réalité sur le chantier la première
chose qui m'a surpris que j'ai ciel et
eau chargée de projet c'est lé problème
de soudure
il y avait beaucoup de problèmes dans la
qualité des soudures la porosité des
soudures qui n'était pas homogène
rené lebrun concept aussi qu'on installe
des équipements complètement brouillé à
bord comme celui-ci en italie et le plus
très souvent le navire n'était pas
protégée contre les intempéries
il y avait énormément d'eau qui rentrait
dans ce bateau là est très souvent on a
eu de l'isolation des panneaux dans les
accommodations des passagers qui l a
fallu défaire parce que tout était sous
l'eau il affirme également que les
normes pour l'application de la peinture
n'était pas respecté je leur ai dit
qu'ils ne respectaient pas les normes
qualité ils ne respectaient pas les
procédures de peinture qui étaient
définis et
donc
on en est là le navire maintenant où ils
prématurément partout et ça va aller en
s'aggravant
j'entrevois que d'ici 4-5 ans va coûter
une fortune en pagne en avion et les
événements semblent donner raison à
monsieur le brol en août dernier
quelques semaines après notre entrevue
avec lui on découvre un nouveau problème
alors que le bateau est en cale sèche
le traversier phagocyte devra subir de
nouvelles réparations c'est en raison
d'un problème d'euros est prématurée et
les chiffres que nous avons obtenu de la
société des traversiers lui donne
également raison
année après année le f à gautschi coûte
toujours plus cher à entretenir et un
rapport que nous avons obtenus révèlent
aussi que des moisissures ont été
découvertes dans les ponts inférieurs
on a corrigé la situation avec des
traitements ou les moisissures se
manifester alors mais l'origine et la
cause n'ont pas été identifiés l'autre
personne qui a accepté de nous raconter
ce dont il a été témoin pendant la
construction
c'est martin st-pierre un vétéran de la
société des traversiers
pendant 15 ans il a été le capitaine du
camille marcoux le traversier qui a été
remplacé par leif à gauthier navire
qu'il a également piloté
il arrive au chant ty en italie après
rené lebron le choix soit comme un défi
merveilleux martin st pierre se rappelle
qu'il y avait bien une personne en
charge du contrôle de la qualité chez
fincantieri
on le voyait jamais jamais jamais seul
chantier je pense qu en 18 matchs et
taylor je dois deux ou trois fois plus
martin st pierre et renée lebrun déplore
aussi que la société des traversiers n'a
pas dépêché suffisamment d'inspecteurs
pour bien surveiller la construction
ils étaient trois et pas tous présents
même temps le chantier travailler 24
heures par jour et nous nous étions pas
là 24 heures par jour
donc quand nous étions absents il est
possible que des choses devaient étaient
cachés les derniers mois c'est
complètement fou il ya plein de choses
qu'on a marqué parce qu'on manquait
d'effectifs normalement on aurait dû
être au moins une douzaine et bien le
défi est énorme et selon martin
st-pierre la surveillance de la société
de classification ne suffit pas vous
êtes ses 148 millions dans un actif sous
la moindre des choses que vous envoyez
votre propre monde pour surveiller vos
propres intérêts labo c'est important
non pour un armateur pour un client de
son veillées sont d'accord vous avez
raison et c'est vrai de dire que dans
nos leçons apprises dans les prochains
projets on voudrait avoir plus de
personnes plus de ressources et pour
suivre le déroulement des travaux c'est
vrai qu'on n'était pas une grosse équipe
mais ce qu'il ya aussi des rangs gironis
lebrun et martin st pierre c'est
l'attitude du numéro un de la société
des traversiers sur le chantier
le chargé de projet luc martin moi comme
les autres inspecteurs ont décelé
certaines anomalies ont référé au chargé
de projet en ayant en espoir qu'il
puisse transmettre nos doléances au
chantier est très très souvent sonné par
prenez le bras estime que plusieurs des
défauts qu'il a signalé à luc martin
n'ont jamais été corrigé benoît corps me
croient que le système n'aurait pas
permis ça
tous les rapports de défectuosités qui
ont été levés par monsieur vous nommer
ou quiconque d'eau ont dû être fermées
corrigés et témoigner au cours de route
alors c'est le système s'est fait comme
ça on l'a appliqué on le fait marcher
et toujours selon martin st pierre et
renée lebreux le chargé de projet lutte
marteil mettait de la pression pour que
des travaux mal exécutés parce quand
même le test j'ai en tête un avis de
défaut sur l'emplacement lors de la pose
des quatre moteurs principaux le
remplacement était pas conforme aux
normes du fabricant
c'est quand même important les moteurs
principaux commence et c'est là que ça
pose et il ya peut-être une décision
d'un gestionnaire
c'est notre rôle pour de attendez on
rencontre le contre tout le monde
respecte ce qui était demandé
c'est correct les caprices ou ce qu'on
veut de plus ou de mieux on va s'en
passer c'est parce qu'on ment
retour en 2014 sur le chantier la
structure
le bateau sera mis à l'eau l'ambiance
est festive mais rené lebron n'a pas le
coeur à la fête
ils croient qu'on laisse le chantier
commettre une nouvelle erreur qui
affectera la qualité du traversier
lorsque l'arrière du navire touche à
l'eau l'avant est encore celui de
lancement donc à ce moment là on est des
efforts d'arqués contre arc qui sont
énormes
toute la structure du navire jusqu'au
pont principal
dans le cas qui nous occupe c'était le
pont numéro 3 devait être soudé à 100%
pour éviter des efforts ou des blessures
sur la structure du navire pendant son
lancement
et qu'est-ce que vous avez constaté au
moment du lancement on avait constaté on
avait signalé aux chargés de projet que
qui naquit n'a pas donné suite que la
structure qui devait être soudé ne
l'était pas complètement
c'était pas notre actif ce n'était pas à
nous de dire aux chantiers navals
important ce qu'on voulait voir si la
réussite des essais la livraison des
certificats et à la livraison des
certificats tous les travaux dassier
était terminé et les l'ensemble la
machinerie du navire ait fonctionné
c'est à dire ne consulter deux
architectes navals puis quand les
soutiens ne sont pas complétés au niveau
du pont au dessus de la ligne de
flottaison
selon les experts consultés c'est
vraiment grave c'est vraiment pas bon
voilà ce même jour benoît qu'hormis tout
chantier naval il est venu de québec
pour prononcer un discours
martin st pierre a tenté lui parler
qu'est ce que vous vouliez limité ben le
contrôle de qualité principalement que
c'était pauvre comme c'est écrit dans
les livres le film katyn ça se passait
pas comme ça tout à fait et sa réaction
il voulait pas m'entendre il voulait pas
entendre ce que j'avais à dire ce que
monsieur saint pierre vous souvenez
quand il a essayé de vous parler des
problèmes sur le chantier vous avez dit
que vous vouliez pas parler ce faux j'ai
jamais refusé de parler de quoi que ce
soit avec mon personnel madame de nick
prenez le bruit n'a plus confiance en
son patron le chargé de projet luc
martin il décide de mettre le supérieur
de ce dernier en copie conforme
moi je voulais absolument protéger dans
cette histoire là et c'est là que les
relations ont été beaucoup plus tendue
donc je m'attendais suite à ces
courriels là à ce que mes supérieurs
m'appelle ou me demandent certains
éclaircissements
ce qui n'a jamais été fait ce supérieur
si benoît cormier il y avait un conflit
entre monsieur là et un autre qui est à
son gestionnaire l'abord qui peut causer
ou avoir causé des frustrations on
s'empêche pas qu'on a un navire comme
celui qu'on a aujourd'hui qui est
certifié qui est fonctionnel sur lequel
on est en train de régler un problème
ponctuel j'ose pas rien mais total tout
c'est un avis ont certifié
certifié ou pas rené le brun 8 craint de
graves conséquences pour le navire ce
que j'appréhende le futur c'est une
dégradation de dans différents domaines
dans ce navire avec une dégradation
accélérée et attendait de voir comment
les patrons de la société des
traversiers ont réagi aux avertissements
ne manquez pas la suite
[Musique]
il est boue et les neuf il vient de
traverser l'atlantique directement
d'italie
voici le f à gauthier en cette journée
d'avril 2015 si l'attraction du port de
matane en fait un équipement moderne
pour la population de l'est du québec
les dignitaires les cadres de la société
des traversiers sont tout sourire mais
il manque une personne qui a mis tout
son coeur dans ce bateau l'inspecteur
prenez le brun et voici pourquoi il est
absent
retournons quelques mois plus tôt à
l'automne 2014 ou chantier de
fincantieri en italie rni lebrun
constate que le chargé de projet luc
martin ne transmet pas à fincantieri des
défauts qu'il relève sur le bateau et à
ce moment là j'ai dû prendre une
décision d'envoyer des courriels
recharger deux projets avec copie à
québec et à partir de ce moment là j'ai
vu un changement d'attitude du chalet de
projets vis-à-vis de moi et à ce moment
là c'était cette agitation qui était
particulière les courriels de monsieur
le bras se retourne alors contre lui au
mois d'octobre 2014 on m'a fait revenir
d'une façon forcée à québec
prétextant que j'étais fatigué benoît
corps me confirme c'est moi qui demande
à monsieur lebrun de venir se reposer
compte tenu des confits que je
constatais fatigué ou fatigants renie le
bras et la patrie à québec
j'ai été voir mon médecin j'ai passé un
examen médical complet à l'hôpital avec
un certificat positif
j'étais absolument pas fatigué j'étais
en forme physique une superforme fiq
mais ce n'était pas la fin de l'histoire
j'ai donné une copie du certificat
médical au président par intérim qui a
eu comme réponse immédiate qu'il allait
me faire faire une contre expertise
médicale par le médecin de la compagnie
ce que j'ai fait le lendemain matin
j'étais voir ce médecin noir qui m'a
regardée qu'en lui l'examen médical de
mon médecin et qui a ri en disant qu'est
ce que c'est que cette bêtise leur celi
des petits à la stq d'envoyer un employé
qui avait un certificat médical de son
médecin disant qu'ils étaient en pleine
forme puisqu'ils étaient aptes au
travail de le faire contre expertise et
pour tenter de prouver qu'ils étaient
pas en forme vous adresserez votre
question ovation humaine ce doublé je
peux pas répondre à ceux ayant échoué
dans leur tentative de
déclare ironie le bras inapte la société
des traversiers le renvoi en italie pour
mieux le congédier une semaine après le
channel projet me fait venir dans son
bureau et me disant que dans 48 heures
je quittais l'état l'ait définitivement
que j'étais en dehors la société
traversée vu une fois de plus rapatria
québec rené lebrun est mis à la porte
pour insubordination
je n'ai pas quand je dis monsieur lebrun
son contrat était terminé de toute façon
pourtant c'est benoît cormier lui même
qui a signé la lettre de congédiement de
rené lebrun à titre de directeur du
bureau de gestion de projet le bjp
ce qui a été très très désagréable dans
cette heure entrevue ce que les
responsables du bg paix non menacées
elles m'ont dit que si je divulguais des
informations dans les médias
j'étais passible de poursuites au civil
nous avons donné la parole à l'ats spq
sur cet épisode que rené lebrun a perçus
comme des menaces nomme denis c'est un
dossier personnel et je ne parlerai pas
de ce dossier je trouve aujourd'hui avec
le recul que c'était tellement
inacceptable man 2 majeur qu'une société
avec des responsables se conduisent
cette façon c'est pour ça que je
témoigne aujourd'hui
en italie c'est au tour du capitaine
martin st-pierre qui critiquait lui
aussi la qualité de la construction
d'avoir des problèmes avec le chargé de
projet luc martin gt reprocher sur des
petits détails là l'utilisation des
toilettes pas la bonne place il y avait
des toilettes qu'on appelle choc on me
voit ce soir qui du coup était chargée
de projet il y avait des toilettes
normal comme on connaît ici au début je
les prenne six toilettes mais on les
règle chantier c'était vous aux faux
premier lesotho l'aide
moi je pense elle la tête c'est un
ridicule
luc martin aurait alors fait voyager
cette histoire de toilette outre
atlantique jusqu'aux réunion des patrons
à québec
je sais qu'il y avait évoqué certaines
problématiques comportementale mais je
suis pour 1 500 m
aei a rapporté à la haute direction la
ftq que j'étais un trouble-fête à sais
que ma directrice eveno new delhi pour
voir ce qui se passait monsieur
saint-pierre votre capitaine du
camille-marcoux depuis l'an 2000 ont été
rencontrés par sa patronne en italie
pour ce faire chic année parce qu'il
utilisait pas les bonnes toilettes selon
monsieur luc martel monsieur martin ont
fait son travail de gestionnaire
c'était la personne en autorité sur le
site et il a dû contrôler la situation
mais pour martin st pierre il n'y a
qu'une explication aux reproches qu'on
lui a adressées
c'est moi parce que je soulevais
beaucoup de problèmes puis est ce qu'on
a essayé de faire taire monsieur cormier
toutes les personnes qui soulevaient des
problèmes sur le chan tsin think ancien
nom le chargé de projet luc martin a
quitté le chantier à deux semaines de la
livraison du fn gauthier personne ne
sait pourquoi
en réponse à nos démarches pour obtenir
sa version des faits il a répondu par
une mise en demeure dans laquelle il
affirme que toutes nos allégations à son
endroit sont fausses
il invoque son engagement de
confidentialité pour refuser nous en
dire davantage fincantieri le chantier
naval a refusé commenté au cours de
notre entrevue le nouveau pdg en poste
depuis six mois semble avoir pris
quelques nouveaux éléments sujet de sa
nouvelle organisation qu'ils ont subi
des représailles après avoir subi des
problèmes qu'ils considéraient important
dans la construction
comment vous réagissait ce fait c'est
inacceptable je juge ces comportements
complètement inacceptable c'est pas la
vision c'est pas l'idée que j'ai d'une
société d'état ou de toute organisation
professionnelle si ces gens là ont des
regrets veulent venir discuter de ce
qu'ils ont vécu avec moi
moi je suis prêt à les écouter martin st
pierre et renée lebrun veulent bien
rencontrer le nouveau pdg
je souhaite pour l'est et qu qu'ils
aient le courage de regarder les choses
en face moi je crois que si l' institut
veut aller vers l'avenir d'une façon
professionnelle
elle doit se remettre en questions d'une
façon très importante